كارثه انسانيه وظروف قاسيه غذاها استيلاء
حركه طالبان على السلطه في افغانستان
ادخلت البلاد المثقله من الحروب في دوامه
مشاكل اجتماعيه عده على راسها الفقر
والبطاله اجمالي الدخل في البلاد تراجع
بواقع 35% ونحو 700 الف شخص فقدوا وظائفهم
على مدار الاشهر الثمانيه عشر الماضيه هذا
التراجع لم يتراكم من عدم فمن اهم العوامل
التي ساهمت في ارتفاع معدلات البطاله في
افغانستان انقطاع الدعم الخارجي واغلاق
مكاتب المساعدات والمشاريع الدوليه اضافه
لفصل الكثير من الموظفين السابقين في
الجهات الحكوميه وتعيين عناصر طالبان بدلا
منهم اما النساء فكان لهن النصيب الاكبر
من المنع من العمل في القطاع العام والخاص
فيما اقتصاديا هناك نزوح لرؤوس الاموال
والمستثمرين من افغانستان وافلاس شركات
القطاع الخاص بسبب وجود الاقتصاديه على
حكومه طالبان ومنع المعاملات الماليه
البنكيه الدوليه كما ان قرابه 65% من
المواطنين يحتاجون الى مساعدات انسانيه
وسط غلاء معيشي قياسي طال ابسط واهم ركائز
المعيشه كالسلع الغذائيه فيما يواجه
الملايين من الافغان خطر مجاعه كارثيه
عوامل اقتصاديه صعبه وفقر قهر العائلات
الافغانيه تسبب في قيام بعضهم ببيع
اطفالهم لاجل تامين لقمه العيش حسب تقارير
لمنظمات انسانيه ولا يزال الافغان يدفعون
الثمن الاكبر منذ سيطره طالبان على الحكم
والتي ادت لعزله دوليه بعد قطع المجتمع
الدولي العلاقات المباشره مع افغانستان